Film Courage: So I think you said earlier
that most of the screenplays that you’ve
sold have been through prior working relationships
where you knew the person.
But when you did go and pitch because it sounds
like you have done that, when someone said
“No,” what did that “No” mean?
Christine Conradt, screenwriter: It meant
that the project wasn’t right for them at
that time.
I think you have to be, you have to have a
lot of confidence in your writing.
First of all to get to that level where you’re
ready to pitch and they are willing to take
a pitch from you are probably at a level where
you know you’re a pretty good writer.
So you can’t let that discourage you.
There are projects that we pitched all over
town that I still love and that I still think
are great projects and no one has bought them
and so it wasn’t the right time for that.
You can kind of obsess over that but the best
thing to do is to keep moving on, go to your
next one, keep moving on.
You can always revisit something later and
a lot of times when you do revisit it you
start to see things about it that you didn’t
see before like “Oh, I should have done
things differently or knowing what I know
now I would do this because you were just
more informed than you were before.
So for me you just don’t let it discourage
you, that’s the biggest takeaway for that.
Film Courage: Did you always have that approach
to it or was the first time sort of difficult?
Christine: I think I always had that approach?
I think my attitude was (and I think I’ve
gotten softer as I’ve gotten older) but
I think when I was younger I was like “Well,
if they don’t like it, forget them.
I’m moving on to the next person.
Like if they don’t get it, someone else
will.”
But I think that’s the right attitude to
have.
And I think that you can internalize a lot
of things as a writer and I think writers
tend to.
We’re always looking for “What did I do
wrong?
What could I do better?
Why isn’t this working for me?”
And I think that if you just stay true to
what you believe in, eventually you’re going
to find that audience that is going to connect
and that producer and maybe it’s just the
timing, maybe you haven’t met them yet but
again it goes to why networking is so important.
Expanding that group of people and networking
and finding that group of people that you
want to work with who creatively align with
you is really, really important.
Film Courage: Yeah and the interesting thing
is too that so many things change behind the
scenes whatever part of the industry that
you’re in and you will never know why and
you’ll never know “Is it me?
What was it?
Did I say the wrong thing?”
Christine: I tell actors this all the time
from a director’s standpoint when they do
auditions and they have five minutes to do
their read, we know the moment they walk in
if it’s a “No.”
Film Courage: Wow.
Christine: And I tell actors all the time
don’t obsess all the time over what you
should of said differently or how you should
have delivered a line.
It’s not even about that.
We either connected you to that character
or we didn’t, period.
And it’s sort of the same way with writing.
You are going to find people who (at one point)
this is the project.
Someone loves this project and it’s what
they want to do and they get it.
But there’s going to be lots of people who
don’t.
That’s why there is lots of stuff on television.
That’s why there’s lots of movies playing
at any given time.
There’s not one thing for everybody, so
don’t take “No” for an answer, just
keep moving.
Film Courage: I like that.